the
libs have gone from trashing
America to endorsing some of America's
enemies to undercutting America's
position in the world to
now
outright endorsing Osama Bin Laden the
latest Tik Tock
Trend this gal she goes me when I got
news in 2011 that we got him yes yeah
great 2023 reading osama's letter to
America knowing he was
right right actually before you even
read the letter I did want to mention in
reading the letter I could only think of
this tweet that I saw the other day
under settler colonialism any kind of
resistance is branded as terrorist
because the only acceptable violence is
Violence by the occupier so please keep
that in mind when reading the letter um
we really need to stop paying taxes
because they ain't doing nothing but
messing up everybody else and and
America is the bully and it's sad
because they have brainwashed us to
America my opin take when in reality
we're the worst country on the planet it
is just insane because this letter is so
well written and so reasonably
structured um in an argument like you
got to present your findings you got to
you know you got to State your cause all
that like everything he said was valid
h h
if you haven't read it Osama Bin Laden
wrote this letter to America after the
911 attacks and I guess Zoomers are just
discovering that I remember reading the
letter many many years ago but the
Zoomers have just discovered it but they
seem to be selectively reading the
letter I'm I'm very excited for the the
libs who are promoting the letter to
America by Osama Bin Laden I can't wait
for these Libs all of whom voted for
Hillary in 2016 to get to the part of
the letter where Osama justifies the 911
attacks in part on America's failure to
punish Bill Clinton for the Monica
Lewinsky Affair I can't wait for them to
read the part of the letter the many
parts of the letter that
contradict all of their behavior I'll
just give you a little snippet the
letter the letter is not too long but
I'll just give you a little snippet here
Osama Bin Laden in the letter to America
writes why are we fighting and opposing
you what are we calling you to and what
do we want from you because you attacked
us and continue to attack us you
attacked us in Palestine Palestine which
has sunk under military occupation for
more than 80 years the British handed
over Palestine with your help and
support to the Jews who have occupied it
for more than 50 years okay that's the
part that the libs like because the libs
are anti-colonialism
anti-imperialism anti- settler
anti-white people anti-british
anti-American and anti-jew okay they
like that part keep reading
though the the people of Palestine are
pure Arabs and original semites it is
the Muslims who are the inheritors of
Moses peace be upon him and the
inheritors of the real Torah that has
not been changed Muslims believe in all
of the prophets including Abraham Moses
Jesus and Muhammad okay do they believe
that part do they believe there's
obviously been a dispute for a long time
between the Muslims who believe that
they are the descendants of Abraham
through Ishmael and the Jews who are The
Descendants
of Abraham through Isaac and uh you know
in in the Book of Genesis it's pretty
clear that those two lines are not going
to get along very well then you add the
Christians into the mix the Christians
who view the church as the Fulfillment
of the Old Testament and the Fulfillment
of the old Covenant and who view our
Lord Jesus Christ as the new Adam and
who view the church as the new Israel
and things start to get really really
complicated here do the libs really they
believe in all of that maybe they do
maybe they do they say yeah the the
Arabs they're the real semites and the
Jews they're not okay well what about
this one you attacked us in Somalia you
supported the Russian atrocities against
us in Chia the Indian oppression against
us in Kashmir and the Jewish aggression
against us in Lebanon yeah yeah that's
right go go get them Osama say the libs
that's right those Americans they keep
they keep uh interfering in places all
over the world okay then then you get a
turn this is why the American people
cannot be innocent of all the crimes
committed by the Americans and Jews
against us what are calling you to what
do we want from you the first thing is
that we are calling you to
Islam so all these livs here you know
many of whom are Reddit to your atheists
I suspect do they agree with that part
of the Osama letter that they all need
to convert to Islam that Islam is the
true religion and they all need to
convert By The Sword is that something
tells me that the tick tock libs are not
quite on board with that one right now
go to expressvpn.com
Michels show it's extremely important to
protect your online privacy with the VPN
and choosing a VPN you trust is equally
as important I can say with full
confidence that expressvpn is the best
VPN on the market here's why number one
expressvpn does not log your online
activity they've developed a trusted
server technology that makes it
impossible for their servers to store
any data at all number two speed
expressvpn does not slow down your user
experience you can even stream HD videos
with zero buffering number three
expressvpn is incredibly easy to use
just fire up that app and tap one button
to connect not just me saying this
Business Insider The Verge and many
other Tech journals raid expressvpn the
number one VPN in the world protect
yourself with the VPN that I trust use
my link expressvpn.com NOS show today
get three months free on a one-year
package
expressvpn.com
noow expressvpn.com
Michels show today how about this one we
call you to be a people of mannerist
principles honor and Purity to reject
reject the immoral acts of fornication
homosexuality intoxicant gamblings and
trading with
interest they agree do they agree with
that
one do they did they put the bong down
long enough to to agree with Osama that
any use or production or trading in any
kind of intoxicating substances
whatsoever is extremely Haram and needs
to be stopped what about homosexuality
and fornication for that matter
are they going to be cheering on that
part of the Osama Bin Laden letter at
their next pride parade is there there's
going to be a section of the of drag
queen Story Hour where they read Osama
Bin Laden's letter about how terrible
fornication and homosexuality are the
libs embracing that part they say it's
saddening that you to tell you that you
are the worst civilization witnessed by
the history of mankind certainly the
libs agree with that you are a nation
who rather than ruling by the Sharia of
Allah in its Constitution and laws chose
to invent your own laws as your will and
desire uh I guess I guess that's true
but the the libs like that that's
exactly how the libs view the law the
libs view the law not as something that
comes from an eternal moral order or an
ordinance of God but rather is something
that we just invent man you know it's
just whatever the people want that's
what we get you know man so uh they
probably don't agree with that
part uh then he goes after the drugs
again and then and then my favorite part
of the letter who can forget your
President Clinton's immoral acts
committed in the official over office
after that you did not even bring him to
account other than that he made a
mistake after which everything passed
with no punishment is there a worse kind
of event for which your name will go
down in history and remembered be
remembered by Nations I love that all
these Lives who if they were alive
during the Clinton era excused him
defended him said that's his private
life he every man has the right to
privacy when he's boinking an intern in
the Oval Office ABS how dare you suggest
otherwise that's why we support Osama
Laden now it seems a little
confusing not to put too fine a point on
it you don't actually have to hand it to
Osama Bin Laden you never you never have
to hand it to him he doesn't have to
have a point it's
okay the libs though are attracted to
the letter by Bin Laden in part because
they hate America and he hates America
so the enemy of my enemy is my friend
but but also in part I think for the
same reason that young men living in
Great Britain 10 years ago young men who
maybe were immigrants or the children of
immigrants but who grew up in perfectly
bgea British middle class lives decided
to give it all up and join Isis forget
about the Immigrant people even the
white guys there were white people who
would go join Isis why it seems insane
why would you leave Britain or France or
America even to go fight for some
Islamic militant group
because you read that letter by the the
by by Osama Bin Laden or any of the
radical Muslims and you see that these
people believe in something they believe
in something Beyond mere physical
comfort and and that is
attractive but unfortunately those guys
never ask the next question well what is
it that they believe in yes there's
something beyond the material world but
what is it that they believe in is what
they believe in true or is what they
believe in false is what they believe in
good or is what they believe in Wicked
and furthermore what should we believe
in are we all just going to become
Muslims cuz Osama Bin Laden told us to I
don't think so maybe I don't know it's
more compelling than just sit around on
your iPhone and believe in nothing I
guess but the reason the reason that the
libs in the year of Our Lord 2023 can
post a Tik Tok Trend like this and be be
swayed by the the ravings of a Muslim
terrorist from 20 years ago is because
we don't know what we believe anymore we
had a religion too we had a civilization
too
we had beliefs beyond the physical
Comforts of this world too and we have
consistently given them up for
intoxicating drugs for weird sex stuff
for derelict Behavior even among
our most prominent politicians that yeah
we did give all that up and that now we
have a crisis of faith and a crisis of
identity and as the cliche goes if you
don't stand for something you will fall
for anything boy what a great clip that
was huh that was good that was good now
you got to ring the bell subscribe to
the Michael nolles YouTube channel and
I'll see you next time